it's an illness that most of us had not
heard of until recently but since may
monkeypox has been spreading here and
abroad leading the director-general of
the world health organization to issue
its highest level alert despite his
advisers failing to agree on it
so in short
we have an outbreak that has spread
around the world rapidly
through new models of transmission
about which we understand too little and
which meets the criteria in the
international health regulations
for all of these reasons
i have decided that the global monkey
box outbreak represents
a public health emergency of
international concern
this means a global response which could
unlock funding and vaccine sharing and
though monkey pox has been around since
the 70s mostly in africa the current
outbreak first emerged in the uk in may
since then there have been more than 16
000 cases worldwide and five deaths with
symptoms including fever lesions fatigue
and headaches all experienced by alex
from brighton
i just woke up and just had this unique
blister on the palm of my hand
and that was like my first thing because
i'd seen
it online before
i was really fevery and just like i've
not felt exhausted like that
and i was literally just like tied to
one position yeah just sweating it all
out
for now the illness is concentrated
among gay and bisexual men it's thought
it can be passed through close contact
but despite the urgency of the who
warning experts say this is unlikely to
be a repeat of the covet pandemic this
is a very very different outbreak and i
think what who have done has signaled
just how far the infection has spread
and usually in europe it's previously
been seen
in western and central africa however
the risk today for most people in the uk
is exactly the same as it was yesterday
reassuring words amid a strong call to
action
milanovinovic sky news